welcome to the Oxford National Guard
Armory I'm glad to see everybody here
today for this very special event I
first of all want to especially welcome
the men of Troop II and the men of the
whole 108th Armored Cavalry Regiment and
the men of the 155th Infantry Division
who were here in 1960 to help save our
community if if you would please stand
and be recognized I would appreciate
that
we're so proud of you and proud of all
the Mississippi National Guard which has
a distinguished history and this unit
here in Oxford - for many reasons
including the events in 1962 but as well
the men who are from this unit who are
presently on a peacekeeping mission in
Bosnia that shipped out of here I think
about a month ago along with several
other soldiers from units across North
Mississippi our thoughts and prayers are
with them on their mission as well as
their families here at home
I think the tragic events of September
11th have given us all deeper
appreciation and awareness for the men
and women involved in Public Safety and
and the military as well some good news
at timing with this event is I don't
know how many of you know on Thursday
night the Oxford Board of Aldermen
approved accepted the bids for the
construction of a new armory and
multi-purpose Center which will take
place beginning in about 60 days at the
end the Sisk Avenue so I'm sure you all
have fond memories of this particular
facility but we're going to be building
a brand new facility and that should be
done I'm not going to say exactly when
it's going to be done
a couple of years let's say we also have
among us a person of singular courage
and determination who changed the course
of our nation and certainly of this
community
mr. James Meredith if you would be
recognized and stand please
he's here with his family welcome y'all
and after the speaker's finished today
we'll have an opportunity for questions
and I hope that he'll answer questions
and if we get started we might be here
all night we're gonna try to get done in
an hour here and I'll be just very brief
if at the after the speakers do get
through and you want to ask questions I
have one request which is that you come
and speak into that microphone right
there because this event is being
broadcast on c-span and that way the
listeners will be able to hear the
question with me on my immediate right
is Jerry Howard the editor of this new
book and American insurrection by
William dual mr. Howard came here from
New York we thank you for coming and
these difficult times of travel he is
I happen to know one of the finest most
accomplished and distinguished editors
and publishers in the American book
business and we're very glad to have you
here today he's going to introduce
William Doyle the author of an American
insurrection but our first speaker today
will be general Chuckie Faulkner a
person who's familiar certainly to all
of us from Oxford it's it's perhaps
interesting that his slightly more
famous uncle sought the world over to
for military heroics ISM and never quite
found it while cookie managed to find it
without ever leaving town
once you read this book you'll get a
very certain idea of what I'm talking
about as well as the bravery of the
people I've already referred to and
people like dr. Jerry Hopkins who's in
the audience with us today and many
other people I'm not going to start
singling out because I won't get through
I was a little bit being your mayor I
have no problem doing this I was a
little did have a little problem trying
to do something that was a book event
because I don't want to be accused of
using my office to try to improve my
business so so what what I will say is I
don't care whether you buy this book but
I do want you to read this book it is a
wonderful it is a wonderful story and
it's available at our library just
across the street and but if they're out
of it you might be able to find it
somewhere else without anything further
it's my great pleasure to give you
Tookie Faulkner
we are all in trouble
they have my nose nothing mr. mayor
letting some against I'm a guest after
though they called me and said come out
here and talk and I said what you don't
talk about and as the order if you want
that later they called me from square
looks that flirty stay will be fine
I thought oh Lord oh when I get through
talking his spine anyway they can all
you folks yes turn ladies and gentlemen
it's an honor to be here
I didn't get scared at the route until
three or four days later I looked at my
Jeep and found a Molotov cocktail it
didn't go off it blew my head off
I got scared then but he was right was
over but I thought what in the world am
i doing down here
good grace is alive he I am a captain
and my military career I call my day to
John John Faulkner told me said when I
finished the ninth grade Russians were
rattling sabers and all that kind of
stuff and he said you got to finish has
to in two years the three-year program
left I said yes sir I finished high
school in that two years because and
year's gonna be drafted so I finished
high school got it three years of
semester or three semesters at Ole Miss
turned 18 he went to Camp Shelby for a
pre induction physical I went down then
I thought after that to a night decent
down there I thought I'm not gonna join
this man's army summer I laugh and say
I'm a draft dodger I joined the Navy
and the folks that went down there with
me got home in a month and twelve months
it took me two years to get home out of
the Navy that's all right
but then that was my guinea beginning my
Navy career and as a seaman and later on
I guess the army needed some offices so
they had a regulation that said anybody
was World War two service which I did a
college degree which are hired passed
the physical indeed got a clearance
security clearance they said raise your
hand and you suck a little I said Sir
Thomas luckily tell what I didn't know
something about to all but I knew a
chain of command
I hate figure that thing out a little
bit uh Navy but anyway that's how I
gotten home in 1955 I thought Godley
Here I am I got a troop and I'm a very
junior captain I've made captain in May
and in November I'm federalized I
thought gracious what am I gonna do now
I just did what I was told to do but I
had change of a strange chain of command
I was used to going you know lieutenant
colonel colonel and all that kind of
stuff but we were federalized Danny and
all me I guess he was about 2130 hours
and the phone running Katzenberg he was
assistant attorney general for United
States under Kennedy
president an opportunity and he's that I
just talked to the president and you're
ordered to come to the Union in order to
come to campus right now I felt gracious
they're not my chain of command I know
the president is commander-in-chief and
all that kind of stuff but I said okay
he said how many are you coming I said
everybody coming oh I believe I met
sections take care of my armory is it
okay and got off the phone with him and
I called my squadron headquarters and
talked to Colonel Williams squadron
commander oh I couldn't get through the
telephones are so tired of it about that
time a u.s. marshal came in the front
door and he said leave well you can't be
funky
are you trying to talk to me my squadron
Florida commander can't get through they
tell me sir prior to one column so I
said prior to one
sheet they plug that thing in and I had
current wings on the phone I said
currently I got a strange thing happened
to me he said on whether they called me
captain falcon of Chuuk ain't no telling
anyways he said what's going on I said
the president kidding just all of my
units at the campus he said what not
told him I said what do I do
and he said camera Thank You bud go
what else I gonna do gosh talk then uh
so we loaded up we left the armory it's
hard you play a player you get my
sergeant major we left here about 21:45
hitch campus about 2,200 bright he took
care of me
anyway we we hit it and I go on out
there how you gonna go to the campus
from here you don't go out there on
University Avenue in it take a ride
going to the campus straight out there
we didn't have any intelligence on what
was going on with him
anyway we got out there and crossed that
bridge the folks started throwing stuff
at us and they were mad and I had
instantly about 2500 people made it me
and my unit and they didn't know me and
I didn't know them but they sure were
mad because they threw everything they
had at us
I had a friend it was building the Oh
biology building at the time and that
Friday he had gotten in all the break
for that building Monday he went to work
that didn't have a brick they were all
scattered all over the campus and most
of them hit me
what I got being real good energy
Hopkins healing my doctor he wanted to
sit mom in the bottom of the last inning
villain was some kind of spleen I was
what he was but anyway they are we got
off active duty no we got all the campus
you know if this armory could talk when
I had it before we hit the campus I was
a young young captain
I wasn't young relevant you capture and
this armory went from my command as the
captain squadron came down and took it
over so had a lieutenant-colonel
regiment came in had a full of bird Karl
and later on at night eighteenth Cole
commander came in three-star he took
over the armory general Abrams the m1
tank his name point but this army has
all had commands up to three stars if we
got off active duty
this became headquarters for use of box
he is armed forces Oxford anyway
I have no idea what I'm doing Oh Lord
but if you really want to find out about
what happened on the campus bill doll
can tell you
in his book cuz I'm just kind of
wandering oh I just kind of wander to
anyway don't have it
but I'm so glad to see all of you here
who it better Ross Brian is he here
past the front yeah I took the first
Passover I took the first unit on the
campus bit arose Brian had the water
valley in it he followed me in about 20
minutes and has the Franklin had the
Pontotoc in it he came in about 10
minutes after there we was the first
three units on the campus and all three
of us got hurt
then the roster still got his steel pot
that's got a huge V in it right there a
brick was thrown at him he ducked his
head hit that thing he had a headache
for a while but uh he just did it anyway
we all survived all this I don't have it
but seventeen folks hurt that night
including me who's from here from true P
Santa true P these are the folks that
took care of me and I appreciate it and
they did a tremendous job we just did we
just followed all roads they were always
supposed to do
I'm to talk yeah you do son
my name is Jerry Howard as you heard I'm
an executive editor at doubleday the
publisher of an American instruction and
I was asked by the good folks at square
books to introduce our author William
Doyle when I heard about this event a
month or so ago from our publicity
Department I thought that it presented
too good an opportunity to get myself
out of New York City the opportunity
became much more attractive later
unfortunately and down to a place the
city of officer in the state of
Mississippi where I've never physically
been before but which I in all aware
Americans have traveled to numerous
times in our literary and historical and
musical imaginations and I was right it
also offered the chance for me to visit
square books a bookstore that has been
justly legendary in the publishing
business for years and which is regarded
by writers and publishers as a bona fide
national treasure and folks having
visited this store and spent time with
its proprietors I can tell you that it
doesn't simply meet it exceeds
expectations I want to convey the deep
thanks of all of the folks at Doubleday
for putting on this event for an
American insurrection and indeed for
being the kind of independent
booksellers that you are
when William Doyle's agent sent me the
proposals for this book on the 1962
integration of the University of
Mississippi and the near conflagration
that it sparked what struck me was not
simply the astounding historical raw
material that that bill had unearthed or
rediscovered but also and especially the
burning passion this author displayed to
set the record straight and to
reacquaint Americans with this half or
even wholly forgotten episode in our
racial and moral history I also noted
that
in the book proposal in the book that
Bill Doyle said he was going to write he
was intent on discovering the real
heroes of this astounding and fraud
incident as well as the villains a
number of those heroes as you have seen
are are here today in this very audience
that passion never flagged in the two
years I have worked with bill and I have
to say that never in the over two
decades of book editing experience that
I've had as a nonfiction book I've
worked on made me feel more intimately
acquainted and involved with his subject
matter
I felt time and time again that I was in
the thick of real American experience in
American instruction is the product is
simply heroic research reporting and
interviewing ladies and gentlemen I am
here to testify that Bill Doyle just
about killed himself to get this piece
of your history in America's history
exactly right and in just the proper
perspective as he'll tell you the book
grew out of his previous publication
inside the Oval Office a book about
presidential taping which led him to the
utterly fascinating Kennedy Ross Barnett
tapes and later his attempt to interest
his then employer home box office in a
documentary or perhaps a docudrama about
James Meredith and the integration of
Ole Miss an American insurrection turned
out to be every bit as gripping as
definitive and as consequential as I
could have hoped I'm proud to be
associated with it as its editor and
publisher and equally proud to be able
to give you its author William Doyle
thank you very much mayor horth general
Falkner Jerry Howard and the people of
Oxford I am so proud to be speaking to
you tonight at the Oxford National Guard
Armory where it was from this very room
39 years ago tomorrow night that a
remarkable chapter in American history
was written by every an incredible group
of American soldiers many of whom are in
this room tonight I speak to you tonight
about Mississippi heroes on the night of
September 30th 1962 the city of Oxford
Mississippi and the University of
Mississippi were forced to pay a
terrible price for the national
contradiction in the national hypocrisy
of second-class citizenship for its
black citizens on that night the city of
Oxford endured an event that US News and
World Report asserted came close to
being a small-scale civil war on that
night thousands of Mississippi National
Guardsmen were forced to make a choice
between their own personal beliefs and
their oath to the American Constitution
this incident was a riot that exploded
into a battle it was a battle that
resulted in 375 casualties military and
civilian over 300 civilian arrests mass
federal confiscation of federally of
privately owned firearms and to innocent
civilians being killed in circumstances
that remain a mystery to this day one a
local boy from right here in Oxford
called ray Gunther gunner and a
out-of-town reporter actually from New
York via England and France named Paul G
hard on in the course of this battle the
battle actually climaxed in a very
little-known lightening invasion of this
state by 30,000 American combat troops
including an armored cavalry regiments
three military police battalions three
infantry battle groups and no less than
1010 Airborne battle groups of
paratroopers of the 101st and 82nd
Airborne Division's this was more
stations than the U more soldiers than
the US had in
riah and six times the amount of
soldiers that were then stationed in
berlin to give you an idea of the scale
of this emergency I first learned of
this story when I was working both on a
book and on an A&E documentary on the
history of white house taping my partner
Carol Fleischer was preparing to
videotape an interview with a Kennedy
civil rights aide named Burke Marshall
who was with the president's side during
this event as we were about to videotape
him he made an authentic comment that
really triggered this four-year journey
of mine that has been accomplished with
the help of so many people in this room
he said that was the night we had a
little war and I thought well if this
country had a little war that I hadn't
heard about probably the truth of what
happened would lie in the hearts and the
memories of the soldiers who fought it I
was amazed by those words and I was even
more amazed by the stories of courage I
began to learn as I researched the story
that's why I wrote this book I was
inspired by these tales of courage I
first came to Oxford three years ago to
interview general Chuckie Faulkner who
in 1962 as you know was captain of the
troop stationed right here and one of
the first things he told me was no one
knows what went on here then and the
second thing he said was it was combat
he made it very clear to me that what
the men of Troop B were forced into that
night was a combat situation in the
middle of our nation now this event was
triggered by a young Mississippi soldier
a black Air Force veteran named James
Meredith it would be hard for us to
imagine an American hero more complex
and more courageous than james Meredith
was in this moment of history there was
a comment made by Medgar Evers who may
be one of our greatest American
authorities on the subject of courage
and he said that James Meredith has more
guts than any man I know
in 1961 james Meredith launched a
one-man legal revolt
essentially against white supremacy in
this state he triggered what Time
magazine called the greatest conflict
between federal and state authorities
since the Civil War
although he was inspired in part by the
heroes of the civil rights movement
james Meredith was not a civil rights
activist he was a career soldier he did
not believe in turning the other cheek
as a strategy for effective social
change in Mississippi in fact in 1961
james Meredith thought that anyone
trying civil disobedience in Mississippi
was crazy because state-sponsored white
supremacy was so powerful and so violent
that it had nearly crushed the civil
rights movement in this state by most
measures of course Mississippi was
considered then the most segregated in
the state in a nation where segregation
was widespread throughout the nation
north-south-east-west and everywhere now
james Meredith believed that the
traditional discussion of civil rights
and this is what I thought was a
fascinating insight that I'd never heard
anybody else point out the traditional
discussion of civil rights was a total
insult to his to the more fundamental
question of whether or not he was an
American citizen for him the issue was
not civil rights but the fundamental
question of American citizenship he
considered his rights as an American
citizen all of them to be non-negotiable
he had spent most of his adult life in
an elite integrated American institution
the US Air Force he had no intention of
allowing his citizenship to be violated
by by anyone he once explained I
considered myself an active-duty soldier
I was at war and everything I did I
considered an act of war he also told me
that he thought he was fulfilling the
idealism of the founding fathers in this
action that he took through a stubborn
and methodical year-and-a-half long
legal struggle james Meredith forced the
US Justice Department the Supreme Court
and the goat to his side and he forced
the governor of Mississippi into a
confrontation not with James Meredith
but with the President of the United
States and the most powerful military
machine in history the US Armed Forces
the governor's vissa City at this time
was Ross Barnett he was a man who was
the son of a Confederate soldier of a
Confederate soldier he was a man who was
a lawyer in private practice championed
civil cases for black citizens but who
in office became a man who Time magazine
anointed as bitter a racist as inhabits
the nation and in order to get elected
Ross Barnett made a deal with the devil
he guaranteed to Mississippi's white
voters that the state schools would
never never be integrated and now that
was a promise he knew he couldn't keep
in response to james Meredith campaign
James Meredith's campaign for 17 days
Governor Barnett and the state
government of Mississippi was in a state
of open rebellion using physical force
to blockade the federal forces from
enforcing the court order to let James
Meredith in to the University of
Mississippi the if this was a state of
open rebellion on the issue of race and
secretly however rosna barnett engaged
in a series of intense bizarre and
almost comic opera phone negotiations
with Attorney General Robert Kennedy and
ultimately the President to capitulate
and allow james Meredith to enter the
university the problem was that Barnett
and Kennedy were like two bullets flying
past each other in history Barnett
wanted troops to be poured into
Mississippi at all costs so he could
save face before his his people and his
supporters that is President Kennedy
wanted troops to never be sent in at all
costs to save face and to avoid the
explosive risks of that at this point in
his presidency we have to remember that
John Kennedy was not a convinced and
devoted proponent of civil rights as a
policy he thought it was in his words a
goddamn mess that embarrassed him on the
world stage he like most Americans had
to be forced to come to grips with this
issue by people like james Meredith and
the freedom fighters and Medgar Evers
and dr. Martin Luther King now as these
secret negotiations stumbled forward
tension was building up not just in
Mississippi but across the country on
this issue too sometimes fantastic
proportions in Texas former US Army
Major General Edwin Walker was issuing
public calls for 10,000 civilians to
blockade Oxford in Los Angeles an FBI in
Foreman reported that 100 volunteer
armed fighters had pledged their support
to general Walker and had already set
off for Oxford a lot of my book is based
on FBI files 9,000 pages of with which
were collected by FBI agents in the
weeks after this emergency and really
reveal a lot of incredible first-person
detail about what was going on there
were town meetings being held across the
state of Mississippi to organize
thousands of people to travel in
caravans to blockade the entry of james
Meredith and the federal marshals
expected on October 1st there were 50
citizens from Orange County California
called themselves the first California
volunteers they got into a bus Caravan
put a flag on the front of the bus and
set off for Oxford this was a tremendous
national surge of interest in the case
and some of it was quite dangerous from
Louisiana Florida and Georgia pledges
came in of tens of thousands of
volunteers the FBI even had a report
that a wealthy Barnett supporter in this
state had or had it arranged for four
canadian surplus p-51 fighter planes to
be flown to Tennessee from Wisconsin to
Tennessee to Mississippi and placed at
the disposal of Governor Barnett
complete with volunteer pilots in
Alabama in Alabama the most powerful and
dangerous Ku Klux Klan leader of the
late 20th century Imperial wizard Robert
Shelton placed the entire membership of
the United Klans of America on standby
alert ready to move on Oxford with
rifles and shotguns
many years later Shelton told me what he
was thinking at this moment in history
this he thought could be another war
between the states after a series of
miscommunications misjudgments and
foul-ups the on the afternoon of
September 30th negotiations between the
Kennedys and Barnett collapsed RFK and
Barnett made a joint emergency decision
to move james Meredith onto the campus
immediately that Sunday night before
tens of thousands of civilians could get
here to Oxford on Monday morning at 8:00
p.m. a chain reaction of
combined to unleash a terrible riot
which pitted several hundred federal
marshals against the mob of several
thousand white civilians it's important
to realize that there were University of
Mississippi students in this riot
especially in the early stages but the
majority of the rioters were probably
not Ole Miss students and very few of
these rioters were from this city from
the city of Oxford the incident was an
absolute disaster in progress for
President Kennedy attorney general
Kennedy because an American city began
collapsing into 14 hours of terror and
mayhem Robert Kennedy later described
this as the worst night of his life and
he described the President as torn
between an attorney general who had
botched things up and the fact that the
Attorney General was his brother in
Jackson the Highway Patrol switchboard
was flooded all night with calls from
Americans who wanted to join in the
insurrection the officer answering the
calls reported that they asked where to
report where to bring their Arsenal's
and weaponry to join the revolt there
were serious people who wanted to join
the rise of the south there was a drunk
from Louisiana who said he'd bring
10,000 people the calls came from as far
away as Wyoming Montana Nevada where do
we report to asked one caller from
California we have vehicles and
munitions we can furnish aircraft for
air support we're ready to go to war one
eyewitness described the scene on the
campus at the University of Mississippi
that night as like we're looking into
your worst nightmare or a small window
into hell this was a ferocious and
chaotic battle that saw US federal
marshals fighting for their lives in
hand-to-hand combat one marshal said I
was more frightened at Mississippi than
I was at Pearl Harbor or any other time
during the war most Americans I want to
say one word about segregation which is
really important most Americans today
would agree I believe the forced
segregation is unconstitutional immoral
anti-american it's a crime against the
Constitution but in 1962 in practice
segregation was a thoroughly mainstream
American ideology north south east
West President Kennedy President
Eisenhower had both spent there into
most of their lives being segregationist
collaborators in the sense that they
spent their whole lives doing very
little to fight it we have to remember
that when we realized that the men of
Truby and the men of the Mississippi
National Guard they told me quite
frankly at the time we were not in favor
of integrating the University of
Mississippi almost to a man that makes
the choice they made tonight that night
from this place all the more heroic in
my opinion now even today racial
segregation in public schools is a huge
problem in our country especially in the
state where I was born and now live in
New York there was a report two months
ago in the New York Post headline New
York leads the nation in public school
segregation intense segregation of black
and Latino students so I think this
discussion of how Mississippi dealt with
this almost 40 years ago is as relevant
today as it was then for all Americans
to learn from Chuckie Faulkner explained
what happened when he moved toward the
campus on the night of September 30th
1962 they entered a combat environment
with small arms being fired at them
intense barrage as point-blank range of
bricks horrible verbal abuse you name it
they went through hell now these were
part-time soldiers local boys and men
who trained two weeks a month
excuse me twice a month in several weeks
in the summer there were 11,000 National
Guardsmen their motto was stand fast
Mississippi which was the phrase issued
by Colonel Jefferson Davis to his
Mississippi troops at the Battle of
Buena Vista during the Mexican War
sometimes people would joke about the
guardsmen and say well your summertime
soldiers but if in an emergency they
were federalized they became regular US
army troops and they had the force face
the same dangers and hazards that a that
men in combat have to although he had
voted against Barnett Tookie Faulkner
was politically conservative and like
many of his men and many white
Mississippians he strongly opposed the
way the federal government was handling
the Meredith case at 9:00 p.m.
Faulkner remembered
I had a troop on my hands eager to join
forces and preserve segregation and
states rights well then he got a call
from Deputy Attorney General katzenback
and when they got to the campus
everything changed one of the men Harold
and one of his men Harold antwine was an
old miss student who said that the two
remembered later we were on the side of
the students in the university we
thought we were being invaded and it was
hard for us to realize that we were part
of the invasion in fact as the trucks
moved out inside one of the trucks was
then 27 year-old Lloyd Gunnar whose
regular job on it was on the checkout
line at the Kroger supermarket in Oxford
tonight he was a specialist fourth class
in the US Army I'll tell you the truth
he told me many years later there were
some mixed feelings than the bunch about
going out there we had one loudmouth in
the truck who said I'll tell you one
damn thing and we get out there I'll get
out there and help them sumbitches throw
rocks
he hates mr. mr. gunner hasten to add it
was not everybody who felt that way as
they barreled west toward the university
Chuckie Faulkner thought to himself this
is a great National Guard unit the
thought never occurred to me that they
wouldn't follow me
Faulkner's parents lived in a house near
the campus by the university high school
and as they approached Faulkner recalled
I caught a glimpse of my daddy standing
out in front of the house I reached over
gave the horn a honk and passed on by
and he then found himself inside a wave
of full-scale combat Ted Lucas Smith the
local local newspaper correspondent said
I clearly remember seeing one boy
standing on the opposite curb with a
huge piece of concrete raised over his
head ready to throw the convoy was
easing along it seemed they didn't
expect what they suddenly got the boy
with the concrete slab waited until the
Jeep pulled even with him and he threw
with all his might the concrete smashed
into the officer and literally knocked
him almost out of the Jeep he saved
himself and pulled him back and pulling
himself back into the Jeep Faulkner
remembered I could see the mob in the
circle and the Lyceum building it
appeared the circle was full of people
and the street on which we were supposed
to
was a sea of people the only lights were
from the Lyceum and the glow from
burning automobiles from here to the
Lyceum building was absolute hell people
would not move out of the street
they threw bricks concrete everything
and anything they could find including
words Faulkner later quipped
it's hard to feel but hard to feel
brotherly love toward people who are
trying to kill you
guardsmen lloyd gunnar remembered that
they were trapped in a sea of fellow
southerners that were trying to kill
them when we crossed that bridge there
was people everywhere that grove was
full of people hollering and cussing
throwing everything to get their hands
on when we ran that blockade we wound up
getting 28 men and men injured on the
way in any of us who didn't know what
side they was on that made up their damn
mind right then now the guardsmen were
swallowed up basically into a human
ocean and basically almost stopped
people getting up onto the trucks and
throwing bricks point-blank at these
young men one guardsmen called out and
said don't throw it at us we don't want
to be here either
that didn't stop the mob one fellow even
stuck his head out the flap and started
calling out the local Ole Miss football
cheer that didn't work either and when
he jumped out of the truck guardsmen
lloyd gunner was greeted by a battered
pulverized band of federal marshals one
of whom said it felt him felt to him
like it was the fourth of July when he
saw those guardsmen coming it made him
want to stand up and wave the flag and
sing and all the marshals cheered and
one of the marshal said to Guardsman
gunner you know I never thought I'd be
glad to see the goddamn Mississippi
National Guard
but you're some good-looking sons of
[ __ ]
still the guardsmen kept coming from
towns like itawamba Fulton Mississippi
Nettleton Belmont and Baldwin from
Tishomingo County Prentiss County and
Ross Barnett's
ancestral Leake County one outfit a
howitzer battery of 108 cavalry was
commanded by Captain Bob Griffin he was
principal of the Nettleton high school
tonight he was leading some of his own
17 and 18 year old students into battle
this was the secret one of the secrets
of the Mississippi National Guard's
perfect performance that night it was
the very structure of the guard itself
it was organized in a town by town basis
where neighbors served with neighbors
and ministers with parishioners and
store keepers with customers and that's
the strongest bond of unit fellowship
and cohesion and it guaranteed that
these GIS wouldn't let each other down
what made it all more terrifying for
them of course is that some of them
thought that there were their own
neighbors or townspeople perhaps in that
mob on the other side trying to kill
them that night there's a scene in my
book where 20 Guardsmen fill in the line
at 11:00 p.m. in front of the Lyceum
this is the high-water mark of the
second confederacy the long Twilight
Empire of white supremacy that ruled
much of the south since after the Civil
War those young men with empty rifles
had to hold the line and keep the mob
from breaking through and massacring who
was inside the building those young men
those Oxford boys held the line they
stood fast and they stayed out there as
long as they could bear it and they
never wavered they never broke ranks as
they were being shot at and had bricks
thrown at their heads and that went on
largely through the hole through the
whole night
in but in fact all 11,000 Mississippi
boys and men had jumped into battle gear
reported to their armories and answered
their nation's call they were very
conflicted about it
one Guardsman said this is the trashiest
deal I ever heard of if Kennedy had
asked for volunteers I don't think he
would have gotten a single one but there
was not a single case of anybody
disobeying orders that night all across
the state these Mississippi men were
deciding that there were Americans first
and the
law was the law they were obeying orders
one fellow said we have no choice we
have our orders and that's it when
you've got to go you've got to go it
doesn't matter what my wife thinks
William Calicut came in with a group of
over 200 men from North East Mississippi
from Senatobia and many of the little
towns between here and there he came in
that night and he looked into the faces
of his men and he saw expressions of
pure terror he told me that he felt
exactly the same way he was the squadron
commander the experienced combat veteran
he said I served two years in World War
two in England France in Germany
1943 to 45 and I never was as terrified
as I was going onto the campus that
night it was the fact that I knew that
there had to be some local people from
my hometown possibly over in that mob
that's what really worried me if we
killed anybody it could be my next-door
neighbor
in fact as he lined up his men with
their gas masks and their unloaded
weapons to march onto campus he called
out the odor the order if you have to
shoot shoot high or shoot low because
you may be shooting your next-door
neighbor finally captain Griffin
explained
I've been continuously amazed that more
people weren't killed
we had boys that just gotten into the
guard with exactly one day's training
our vehicles were stopped and surrounded
by rioters our weapons meaning the
weapons in his outfit were locked and
loaded and each man had a clip of live
ammo I'm amazed we didn't shoot now in
1999 guy gravely told me what he thought
the secret of the guards perfect
spectacular performance was this Knight
quote they were like me they didn't want
to go over there I can get involved in
this thing because we had to live here
and do business with some of these
people but they were disciplined a
number of the noncommissioned officers
were veterans of World War two and Korea
they took over and did their duty they
were magnificent leaders on the subject
of heroes John Kennedy and Robert
Kennedy were often thought of as Civil
Rights heroes in some way in some ways
they were but I was amazed to learn that
during this action according to detailed
Pentagon records and lots of eyewitness
testimony a
attorney General Robert Kennedy secretly
ordered 4,000 black soldiers
paratroopers military policemen
infantrymen to be stripped off the front
lines of this action and forcibly
segregated during the invasion and
occupation of Oxford he did it
apparently to avoid the political
embarrassment of having black troops
with high-powered rifles in charge of
Mississippi streets many of these black
troops were disgraced disarmed and
forced to do non-stop KP and garbage
duty now you have to remember in 1962
the million-man US Army excluding the
National Guard was well integrated in
the lower ranks the sergeants the
privates integration was working very
well in the army and many of the white
soldiers were even more outraged at the
stupidity of pulling units apart which
would then destroy their ability to
function not to mention the humiliation
of this nearly forty years later a
number of the white and black veterans
expressed to me their outrage and
disgust at the disgrace of resegregate
which was all the more offensive as one
black military policeman told me in his
words when you consider what the hell we
were sent down there for to integrate
the University of Mississippi or to help
in that effort
there were many genuine heroes of the
Battle of Oxford in addition to James
Meredith and the men of the Mississippi
National Guard there was Duncan gray
then the rector of st. Peter's Church in
Oxford when he heard about the riot he
snapped on his clerical collar marched
into the riot and started running around
the battlefield talking rioters into
surrendering their weapons the he
repeatedly stepped into the path of mob
mobs charging the Lyceum building and
pleaded with them to stop he was using
his body as a human shield his wife
later explained he didn't see it as
courage Duncan just didn't know any
better
he was a priest and that's what a priest
did on that day for him it was as much a
part of his vocation as lifting the
chalice on the Eucharist that Sunday
morning at one point when performer
general Walker was haranguing the mob to
charge
Duncan gray climbed up onto the
Confederate statue and tried to stop him
before he gray was pulled down and
beaten by the crowd there were the
hundreds of federal marshals border
patrol guards federal prison guards who
were sent to Oxford almost totally
unprepared and were forced to fight for
their lives in hand-to-hand combat to
uphold the law of the land there were
the men of the 503rd Military Police
Battalion an extraordinary fully
integrated crack force of riot fighting
soldiers from Fort Bragg who were
dropped into Oxford at the peak of the
fighting and performed spectacularly
their white commanding officers by the
way took the written order to segregate
the black troops out of the battalion an
order approved by the Attorney General
of the United States tore it up and
dropped it into a garbage can at Fort
Bragg there was Jerry Hopkins the local
doctor from Oxford who volunteered to
travel into the battle zone and set up
an improvised one-man combat field
hospital as a sniper methodically
blasted away at the window a few feet
from his head he stayed up all through
the night treating scores of injured
soldiers reporters marshals and
civilians there were students like buck
Randall who tried to stop the fighting
as bullets flew over his head and others
who acted as bodyguards for trapped
reporters there was a young student from
pasty gula by the name of Trent Lott who
spent reportedly spent the whole night
sending runners around and gathering his
fraternity brothers at Sigma Nu and try
to gather them in one place and keep
them safe and out of trouble
there was Charles Boland a Mississippi
officer of the Regular Army 2nd Infantry
Division whose troops took a terrible
beating from rioters on the town square
he these troops held their fire and
secured the center of Oxford the dignity
of his troops the dignity of his troops
under
attack was in the words of one
eyewitness little short of inspiring
including his black troops especially
together with James Meredith and the
many hun sung heroes of the Battle of
Oxford this country fought and won the
last battle of the American Civil War as
dawn came on October 1st 1962 this was a
symbolic turning point in American
history that marked the death of massive
resistance to integration among the many
mysteries of this story is the question
of why it's been largely forgotten by
history one reason was the Cuban Missile
Crisis was to three weeks later and that
kind of erased this from many folks
memory banks the second reason is there
were very few photographs taken of this
battle it was at night and it was
extremely dangerous and reporters were
getting attacked and in some cases
killed and begging for their lives so
that so it was covered in a very
fragmentary way but there was one reason
that amazed me
I found a memo and the Pentagon files
that explains why we didn't hear as much
of this as we should have the army brass
put in four medals for you men and for
the military policemen the infantry men
who came in after you they recommended
that you get medals now this made it all
the way up to the United States
Continental Army command in Fort Monroe
of Virginia here's the memo that
responded to the recommendations
recommend disapproval of the award of
the Army Commendation Medal and here's
the reason it is considered that the
focus of additional attention on this
incident
would not be in the best interests of
the US Army or the nation the award of
decorations would probably result in
publicity which even though local in
nature would rekindle publish public
emotions it is the position of this
headquarters that decorations not be
awarded for actions involving conflict
between US Army units and other
Americans this when Martin Luther King
jr. wrote his letter from a Birmingham
jail in 1963 he predicted that someday
the south will recognize its real heroes
they will be the James Meredith's
courageously and with a majestic sense
purpose facing hostile and jeering mobs
and the Anglin izing loneliness that
characterizes the life of the pioneer
this nation owes a great debt to james
Meredith for having the vision and the
physical courage to do what he did in
1962
we also America owes a great debt to the
men of Oxford's troop Oxford's troupe II
and all the soldiers of Mississippi
National Guard
Chucky's Faulkner happy antwine Duford
bad-boy gunner landon franklin william
callicut viet guy gravelly gray megan
s'en william austin hassel Franklin
Billy Roz Brown and Robert Crowe and to
their brother soldiers of the hundred an
eighth Armored Cavalry Regiment the
155th Infantry Regiment and the Regular
Army troops who followed them into the
Battle of Oxford when the book of
American courage is written I think
there'll be a special place for the men
of the Mississippi National Guard who
placed their duty above their personal
feelings their oath above their personal
safety and their nation above all else
you risked your lives to restore law and
order to a part of our nation that had
fallen into anarchy like your brother
and sister Mississippi Guard members who
today are helping keep the peace in
Bosnia and like the many Mississippi
heroes who have traveled to my home city
of New York to help in the recovery
efforts there you define the meaning of
patriotism not through your words but
through your actions you save the great
University rescued an American city and
upheld the American Constitution during
one of its severus trials on a lost
forgotten night of horrors through your
discipline your professionalism and your
courage you prove what it means to be
American on July 21st my 1861 Chucky's
Faulkner's great-great-grandfather
Colonel William Faulkner commanding the
2nd Mississippi Infantry Regiment at
Manassas led a charge toward Union lines
with a stylish feather jammed in his hat
a Confederate general saw him and called
out to his troops men follow yonder
night of the black plume and history
will not forget you I hope that in the
generations to come history will never
forget you the men of the Mississippi
National Guard and what you did for your
nation and this
so many years ago I know I never will
thank you
thank you
it would be great if we have James
Meredith with us we have the men of the
108th armored cavalry cavalry
we have Billy Ross Brown who arrived
just a little late and I believe dr.
Hopkins is here I would be most honored
if if perhaps dr. Meredith could could
join us and answer any questions you
would have and if any questions you have
for any of the men of the guard or for
dr. Meredith might be addressed if you
could perhaps use that microphone that
would be just great if you had any
questions about the book or about
anything at all here
don't be shy now
you may not may or may not remember mr.
Meredith but you used to coming into
Union Grill at Ole Miss and I would
serve you two fish sandwiches at night
and you would never stay there and eat
them you would take them in your tooth
federal marshals in turn go back to your
dorm and I think that's the testimony
that what he was trying to do he wasn't
flaunting racism or anything like that
he would have stayed in Eaton with the
students but he took his sandwiches he
went back to the dorm thank you thank
you
I just wanted it
Billy Ross Brown would raise his hand
because we weren't able to acknowledge
him earlier I am just oh there he is
thank you for coming very much
masks where dr. Jerry Hopkins is oh
there is thank you doctor
mr. Dahle could you give us the timeline
of when Ross Barnett stood up at the
football game the night before the riots
39 years ago tonight in fact that night
we played the University of Kentucky and
Jackson the Ole Miss play Kentucky today
the score is 41 to 30 year one by a but
and very famously Governor Barnett got
up at halftime of that game in Jackson
and said that the University of
Mississippi would never never integrate
and brought the house down obviously and
he knew full well that he had already
cut a deal with attorney general Kennedy
can you give us a timeline of how long
had it been since they had that phone
call and the time he got up in the
stadium and exhorted the crowd the way
did I think sure but and I did want to
mention that James de Meredith has
written a wonderful book on this whole
chapter of history the name of the book
is three years in Mississippi I would
urge anybody interested in this period
young or old to consult that book
because it tells you the courtroom
action and all the background personal
and historical that dr. Meredith went
through in this epic journey so I would
commend that book to you directly in
terms of the timeline Barnett was in and
I want to ask dr. Meredith a question in
a second but the the timeline was that
weekend Barnett Robert Kennedy John
Kennedy we're all talking to each other
and a round robin series of phone calls
Barnett Ross Barnett knew that james
Meredith was coming into the university
he knew he could not beat the federal
government but what Ross Barnett yearned
for was a photo of guns drawn at him
literally dozens of guns drawn at his
body so he could then step aside and let
James Meredith and the federal marshals
come in the time line was very tight in
the 29th and 30th he spoke to the
audience for 39 years ago tonight at
this time almost and gave a very
inflammatory favorite famous speech and
who knows what he was thinking he was
going in different directions at
different times I wanted to ask James
Meredith if he might to tell me
something that I found was amazing James
Meredith told me three years ago the
Heath
that Ross Barnett managed this crisis
perfectly and that no blacks were
injured during the time and he held Ross
Barnett personally responsible for that
I just wondered if I could ask you to
elaborate their lab rate on that if you
could is a fascinating idea James
Merritt
I'll do that first I thought I was gonna
get up here and get a chance to read my
statement that I worked two weeks
working on well I said then and I wrote
then and even in three years in
Mississippi but my time is a little
sword I said in 20 years Mississippi
would once again be at the very top in
America most people don't realize that
Mississippi was the richest and most
developed state in the Union before the
civil war began and I've always
predicted that it would be again Ross
Barnett
my mother had 14 brothers and sisters
the youngest one was like a lot of
families 6 to 8 years younger than the
old ones
he knew Ross Barnett better than he knew
any of his own brothers and sisters they
did everything together
so I've heard it said he even mentioned
that Ross Barnett in his book he says
that a black man got hit by a car
hurt real bad and asked him what doctor
and they wanted to take them too he said
just take me to dr. Ross Barnett
because you see all these
ever-tightening now about these personal
injury lawyers and make me but that's
what Ross bought not dead then but he
did it for blacks as well as whites
nobody else did now believe me Ross
Barnett knew what he was done when he
protected everybody
in this state made sure every white in
this state look to him to take care of
the problem not feel that they had
themselves go out and take care of the
problem now I wrote it in case I didn't
get a chance to say it but it's only
about 90 seconds I'm going to read
because I tell you what I really think
that today represents the greatest
opportunity that I've ever lived to see
and that's the opportunity to tell you
in Oxford Mississippi why the Battle of
Ole Miss took place the goal of the
founding fathers was for first-class
citizenship for everyone this was
particularly true of General George
Washington of the greatest the most wise
the most important of all those who
founded the United States the people of
the United States who were intended to
enjoy the rights and privileges under
the Constitution will cause citizens
George Washington sister
that that would be only one class of
citizenship unlike the practices and in
the Roman Empire and the British Empire
where citizenship had been divided into
different classes slavery was the way of
life slavery was the way of the world
when the United States was established
whether it would remain the standard was
the largest question facing mankind in
1987 1787 in 1865 this question was
answered by the War Between the States
and the srage was set free and made
citizens indeed for a short period of
time George Washington's dream of
everyone enjoying citizenship right was
a reality however the United States
quickly reversed itself and established
classes of citizens with some people
enjoying our rights
and some entitled to less that is what
the Battle of Ole Miss was all about
citizen would it mean what George wasn't
intended or something less now it is
2001 the United States faces an even
bigger question than the founding
fathers faced in 1787 the question is
whether anyone will be able to enjoy the
rights of a free people and I heard
George Bush said many times at the
beginning of this new war in his wisdom
and very few people know this better
people know how important George
Washington is to America and his wisdom
George Washington provided us with the
framework needed to answer this question
he said that there are four things
essential to the well-being and to the
very existence of the nation as an
independent power number one an
indispensable in dissolvable Union on
the one head number two a sacred regard
for public justice number three the
adoption of a proper military policy and
peace establishment number four the
prevalent the prevalence of a specific
and friendly disposition among the
people which will induce them to forget
their prejudices and policies and to
make concessions to the general property
and to sacrifice their individual
advantages to the community as a whole
we have a union on the one hand our
public justice must be put in order
something is wrong when one group make
up only one only ten percent of the
population and over half of those in
prison
our military policy must be changed we
must adopt the military policies used by
the Romans and the British during the
time that they were the main
hours in the world finally the new
United States will have to completely
get rid of the system of superiority in
theory it simply will not work in this
new age equality must become a reality
in the United States and I got a mate in
copper
thank you very much dr. Meredith are
there any other questions ma'am I want
to thank you for having such a fire in
your belly over this issue and for still
having a fire in your belly dr. Baron
about this issue I'm a service member
I'm a reservist I'm also an eighth grade
teacher in Oxford Mississippi and very
committed to this place and every year I
really try to rally my students to think
about America it wasn't so hard
this year especially recently and when
they heard I was going to be activated
it was more real to them on hold right
now I expect to go soon but I wonder for
either one of you what your
recommendation so I do my teacher voice
for you dr. Meredith well your
recommendation would be to work with the
children so that they are aware of this
issue which still lives in schools in
Mississippi and the nation this issue of
racism it's still prevalent in public
schools perhaps not in private what
would your recommendation be to speak to
the children about this matter
how can we fix it now my thought would
be and I'm speaking not only from my
heart but from what I've been hearing as
you probably have noticed you haven't
heard blacks say much of anything since
this thing happened okay now the reason
is very simple in the past for every
major crisis World War One World War two
the Korean War the Vietnamese the
Vietnam War I can't speak for the Gulf
War what has happened everybody had to
acknowledged that they were second-class
citizen
in order to prove that Lord to America
and be part of the team well every black
I know is scared to death that's what
they gonna have to do now and most of
them are not willing to do
I thank : power and kind of Lisa Christ
might be but the rest of them are not
willing to do it now we've been teaching
civics real good there are very few
people in America don't believe that all
citizens the election last year would go
the whole issue was every citizen should
have the right to vote and every vote
should count now what they were really
talking about is dual class citizenship
that's what America has to do and I
believe that Mississippi is the place
that's going to lead that I mean I
genuinely believe that Mississippians
are ready to either make this America
real or leave it
mr. Meredith I see you as being a hero
you know for going to the Ole Miss and
doing what you did my name is Spanky
Foster I lived in La Fayette County all
my life and I would listen to my
grandmother my mother talk about the day
that all of this went down and they did
nothing more than talk about it and tell
what happened but they never tagged any
little like message to it like he was a
great hero like Martin Luther King
Malcolm X this that nothing but I got
sense enough to see that you was a hero
but does it bother you that they're
white people today here patting you on
your back for what you did and not more
black people can you elaborate on that
just tell me something well when you get
a chance to read this book you will see
that he in the beginning point out that
I said that in the future I was going to
be the greatest leader in the black
world in America and the whole world but
in the end of the book he not always
said EJ and Meredith ain't no leader
that he ain't nobody ever recognized him
for nothing
I mean now you got to understand the it
may be a thousand years before people
understand what I just talked to you
about about citizenship you see I mean
they it may be a thousand years I mean
they I had a man that come up here today
and tell me he marched behind me in the
line to get as a plumber at the
University of Mississippi because his
name came after mine now and he said he
saw me every day on the campus but he
never spoke to me in his life until
today now the soul but today for
whatever reason he was ready to shake my
hand
and speak to me he didn't say it
but the impression was that he had
gotten a message different from the
message that he'd had all of this time
now what I really think is that the
founding fathers were really wise man
they really were and they were good me
you understand George Washington could
have been called royalty he would not
allow that and he knew exactly what he
was doing and half of the people were
slaves back then we don't like to talk
about it but almost half of the white
people were slaves or descendants of
slaves back then you don't hear that
anymore I mean but it's the truth and
and we all know it's the truth okay now
we've there's no 10:00 in the morning if
you were an indentured servant if your
parents come from that there's no and
there's nothing against that now the day
gonna come when nothing would be against
being black any other thing but only the
Americans can make that and I think it's
gonna start right here in Mississippi I
don't know if I answered your question
but basically I've known all along that
people mainly wouldn't understand in
fact in his book he point out most of
the things I did was done for people to
understand 40 years later it's not even
40 years yet so yeah I am NOT surprised
and I know exactly what you're talking
about I mean they everybody talked about
James Meredith but don't nobody know
what to do with him
yes sir I was curious to know what your
family members and your parents what
their advice to you at the time was were
they you're doing the right thing you
need to finish this thing out and and
fight and go through it or were they we
know you're doing the right thing but
we'd rather not see you get hurt and you
know what was the perspective on that
well the
I don't like the hog the show but this
is really nothing unusual I think I mean
I usually dominate everything I touch
now but to answer your question which is
the very significant question I'm 68
years old I still yet have to anything
to do that was my idea
you see people give me credit for what I
don't deserve I don't deserve the kind
of talk that you talk about because I
didn't do it
everything I did was basically my father
but my family yeah I mean even you have
to read some of my books to get this my
father's the one that engineered Ole
Miss I didn't he told me what to do he
told me when to look like I was losing
and when they act like I was winning I
mean he told me when you know they shot
up my house his house okay he came and
won me three or four days before that
that the in Kosciusko for the first many
months the high class whites the citizen
council whites were running everything
but at a certain point the Lowell area
the other group took over and he knew
exactly when that happened and he drove
the Jackson and told me you understand
that the situation of the changes got
real dangerous and you know who shot up
my house it was that a local Kosciusko
police do you understand that now I mean
the so he not only was the engineer
behind it he was the one that did all of
the strategy I mean the soul it was
you really would have to understand and
Ole Miss got all my papers and which
I've written all of this down see but
you got to understand who I am and even
mr. darling quite figured that out yet I
mean you see my great-grandfather was
the last National selected ruler of the
Choctaw Nation when he was the ruler
when it was dissolved in 1830
if the Choctaw Nation was still a nation
my father would have been the leader now
I was commissioned from birth that my
duty was to restore the power and the
glory to my bloodline and one of the
shortcomings I had I did not realize
that other people didn't have a history
similar to mine so I really didn't
understand the reason other people were
doing the thing that they did so
basically you really have to understand
that I still I hope I live long enough
to be the engineer of some idea but I am
still my father been dead 30 years I am
still fulfilling his mission I haven't
got to mine yet so I don't know if that
answers your question I hope so
dr. Meredith would you recite sort of in
chronological order what time what
happened to you that Sunday and were you
made aware of what was going on what
time you came down at Sunday afternoon
and and then when you started class I
believe one of your first professors was
dr. Claire Marquette who incidentally is
still alive and lives in Louisville I'd
like to know how you were treated by
your faculty members and other students
after the hullabaloo that happened that
Sunday night occurred well I don't know
exactly the time because we flew for
Memphis but we left Memphis probably
around 4 p.m. and we flew into the I
guess the Oxford Airport out north is
still the same location and there were I
don't know it looked to me like still my
heart that I don't know but there were a
lot of United States and marshals out
there and trucks and they loaded up and
I got in one of the cars and they drove
us onto the campus I went to Baxter Hall
which was my hall the whole time and I
stayed there about a tocar John Kennedy
President Kennedy came on saying that I
was on the campus and and so forth and
frankly I went to sleep after that
and I didn't really wake up till the
next morning and the marshals came in
and the car that we rode over to the
Lyceum in all of the windows were shot
out they had to go back in the room and
get two or three blankets to put over
the glass so we wouldn't get cut so
that's when I really knew what had
happened and we registered and all of
this is not in such detail but it's all
in mr. dog book and I went to the first
class what she was dr. Marquette as you
say and of course he knew who I was in
his car so when I got in they acted like
nothing had happened
and so the monsters tried to come in
behind me and he asked them to stay
outside and that's not a pattern
and of course nobody I guess I was 10 to
15 minutes late so he just continued to
talk so nobody said anything but that
was the way it was but you got to
understand I was not a student I never
considered myself to be a student I was
a soldier I was at war I can I
considered to be quite frank if there's
anything that surprised me out of the
whole year was that I was still living
believe you me if I had been me and been
on the other side I wouldn't still be
living I mean they show that but I have
no complaints about how anybody treated
me then and I really absolutely have no
complaints about how people treat me now
I mean not absolutely not
if I just add one thing I remembered
being very impressed by and amazed by
was you also have to understand that in
this crisis james Meredith was in charge
of pretty much the whole operation what
I mean is there was an attempt made to
bring James Meredith with federal
marshals spotter planes an elaborate
federal attempt to enter Oxford one day
and James Meredith remember he was
acting on his own some folks have
misunderstood this over the years
thinking that james Meredith was somehow
selected by the n-double-a-cp or he was
on somebody's payroll he was an American
citizen armed only with the American
Constitution and this entire operation
as a citizen he had the power to call a
stop to it and he did that one morning
when the federal parade was gearing up
to bring him in down into Mississippi
from Memphis James Meredith called a
stop to it
he just said we're not going anywhere
you guys aren't you don't have enough
force this is insulting my citizenship
before the whole world you have to get
serious about this with force and the
federal people pleaded with him and he
wouldn't budge and that's a testament to
how one citizen can use the Constitution
I really as a weapon to deliver his own
rights of citizenship yes sir
thank you for coming um when I've read
your book mr. Meredith and when I've
thought about these events
I've often puzzled and maybe you mr.
Doyle and mr. Meredith could comment on
this I've puzzled over the behavior of
President Kennedy during this incident I
mean we know that he spoke quite a bit
with Burnett by telephone and of course
he spoke to the nation by television on
the evening of the events but suppose
County had come to Oxford in person and
been here either that night or for a
while earlier do you think he could have
improved the situation or changed what
happened that way I can give that a shot
then I'll turn it over dr. Meredith
three interesting things about President
Kennedy in this crisis number one I
think he was trying to do the right
thing as best he could without exerting
too much political risk a big caveat
number two he was forced by james
Meredith and by history into an
impossible set of choices it was a
choice between blunders he either
dropped a crack division of a thousand
Marines and battledress into Ole Miss to
secure the campus before the riot
happened or he would try to do it in a
mid way in an intermediate way with a
minimum force and what happened was that
was a misjudgment also second
interesting thing about President
Kennedy is that again he was I think he
had lost control of this crisis Ross
Barnett was running circles around him
he out really out outfoxed him in many
ways and as a result the emergency
happened at eight o'clock that night but
also there's an intriguing bit of
evidence that President Kennedy every
month he was visited by a quack doctor
in who came from New York and dr.
Jacobson dr. feelgood was his name and
he shot the president full oven feta
means once a month on and on average and
this was then considered to be a
Hollywood sort of thing to do it wasn't
that dangerous it was known to be that
dangerous it was very dangerous in dr.
Jacobson's personal journal journalist
Richard Reeves found a detailed notation
that max Jacobson dr. feelgood had been
summoned by the president by private
plane
the night of this crisis to go to the
White House and shoot him up in
preparation for the national address at
eight o'clock and President Kennedy
explained to the doctor this one is a
ballbreaker that's why he needed the
shot now did it make him fly off the
handle I don't think so it did it make
him John Kennedy be more John Kennedy
that's probably what happened but it
shows the kind of pressure he was under
dr. marrows well you know one of the
most famous statements Ross barn ever
made I love Mississippi I love the
people well Barnett loves black people
there are a whole lot of white people in
Mississippi that love like people that
don't ever say it I mean they now if you
listen to the tapes between Barnett and
and President Kennedy it'd be pretty
hard to know which one was Kennedy which
one was Barnett they're both Irish and
so the voices of pretty much alike but
President Kennedy always referred to me
as the boy Mr Barnett always referred to
me as mr. Meredith and he straightened
the president out one time so but most
people even Mississippians don't realize
that one two ounces the difference
between New York he just heard somebody
up here say that New York today is the
most segregated state in the Union I
guarantee you that the rest of America
and
have been two ounces better than
Mississippi ever you understand that I
mean the so the the the Kennedy's I tell
you I trusted Barnett a whole lot more
than I did the Kennedys number one John
Kennedy was the last president of the
United States dependent to spend the
night in the governor's mansion in
Jackson Mississippi that still go
through until this day Ross Barnett
could not be reelected governor
Mississippi because of the law John
Kennedy desperately wanted to be
reelected to president of the United
States and I guarantee you he would have
sacrificed all 25 or 30 million black if
he was sure that that would got him
elected president so that's the truth of
the matter so I hate to hog the show
thank you
directly to your point one fascinating
thing about this crisis is i would argue
that james Meredith engineered a turning
point in history that night two amazing
things happen number one massive
resistance to integration that was dead
when the dawn came on October 1st 1962
there were terrorist actions there was a
lot of turmoil this country went through
after that but massive resistance a very
dangerous segregationist theology was
dead number two Anne done perhaps an
unintended consequence is that the
Republican Party was reborn in this
country in the South weeks after this
event just a few weeks you can trace the
rebirth of the Republican Party exactly
to the midterm elections of 1962 that
was a symbolic turning point that we're
still living through today and again I
think that james Meredith deserves all
the credit for that so thanks very much